hey everybody welcome to another episode
of
stevo's wild ride and now we've seen me
get pretty excited about some guests in
the past
but never have i been more excited
than for sharon osbourne man i'm a
lifelong aussie fan
everything about the osborne's kicks ass
so
let's get into it ladies and gentlemen
sharon osbourne yeah
yeah yeah what an honor i can't even
believe i was
frankly surprised that you agreed to do
this
and uh i couldn't have been more
thrilled about it why
why are you surprised i've known you
since you were a little boy what the
[ __ ] are you surprised about
now speaking of when i was a little boy
okay
i want to show you this uh
framed picture right here maybe
you recognize it this is print
number 21 of 90 in existence
now knoxville bought this print for me
because uh he just knew what a
crazy maniac fan of ozzie i've always
been
and what's unbelievable knoxville didn't
even know
is that this picture was taken off ozzy
and maybe i believe even wimbledon but
certainly in london
in 1974 and i was born
in wimbledon in 1974.
so essentially this is a picture of ozzy
when and where
i was born oh my lord that just gave me
goosebumps yeah tell me about it oh it
gives me goosebumps all the time
i i just i just love it so much and uh
you know i know that there's just so
much that i want to ask you
and and again i can't say it enough how
thrilled i am to have you
um i i like i said was just such a fan
of aussie aussie was
the gold standard for me when it came to
excess
success being out of control on drugs
and alcohol i always just
aspired to party like ozzy to
be crazy like ozzy and uh as a nod to
him
in 2003 i got the words [ __ ]
and [ __ ] tattooed on my knuckles
oh my god i got to show that to him one
time at the jay leno show
now that i had those tattoos for over 10
years
and the and i'm so fiercely proud of the
fact that they never
held me back they never got in the way
they never caused any problems
but ultimately they did outlive their
usefulness and i got them lasered off
right good for you yes yeah
so uh first off how have you been
with uh with everything going on jesus
uh listen i can't complain because we're
all well
and thank god you know the family has
not got
any of this virus and so we're blessed
you know it's um i think the most thing
is it just [ __ ] with your head
yeah just really [ __ ] with your head
because
every day the rules to this virus change
they tell you one thing then it's
another
and you know it's oh don't worry it's
gonna go when the when it gets hot
well it's [ __ ] boiling and now
there's more cases than ever
right right you know so it's like every
day that the rules change but listen
we're fine
and and where are you today are you in
la are you in london
we're in l.a yeah uh-huh fantastic and
sharon if you hear somebody else talking
i'm scott randolph i'm steve's co-host
he's i'm good he's three for 15 from
introducing me
and if you hear another interesting
voice that's going to be paul briskey
over there
he's our engineer slash producer hey
sharon how are you good thank you
it's a pleasure i i think steve is just
really excited about this one
uh when we were talking we were coming
back from new mexico and we were like
you know we might have sharon osborne on
the podcast
he broke down the whole entire story of
how much he loves you and his
relationship i know he has a ton of
things to talk to you about
well yeah it was it was a roughly
12-hour drive and i would say it
a good two three hour three hours was
devoted to me
giving him some history about about the
osbornes
and um you know most notably i think
this has just got to be some kind of
like really impressive world record
is the fact that black sabbath was such
a
like just a you know arena rock huge
you know successful band and
they actually kicked ozzy out right
because he was just too much out of
control with drugs and alcohol
as is how i understand it and
for all of the say that michael jackson
leaving the jackson five
where you know justin timberlake leaving
in sync you know for all of the
the people who have have left bands and
gone solo
to eclipse the success of the band that
they left
is there another example of somebody who
did that
however the circumstances of them
leaving the band was they got kicked out
right that's i just can't imagine that
that's ever happened
i don't think so the nearest one i can
think of is sting and he left
so you know right um yeah
sting would be in there with michael
jackson with justin timberlake
and uh it's just that um
in especially in this genre of
of a you know the band that they were in
their genre it was just
never done the singer would always you
know just
go into isolation well right i mean ozzy
had his own reasons for going into
isolation
he would just snap and then shave his
head and then go into a hotel room for
months
and i remember because i uh my formative
years were in
in england i uh we went to the american
school in london and and so
you know i got into all of this living
in london i actually had the same
dentist
as ozzy uh when i was in you know
in uh in grade school and uh i would see
karang i would you know all these
magazines and ozzy would have all these
different hair lengths
um but it's just it's just so
fascinating and
with with black sabbath uh
it was actually your father who managed
black sabbath
that's correct yes and i worked for my
father
yeah right and so then when
when black sabbath kicked out and kicked
ozzy out
uh that was uh you guys were not already
together at that point
no uh we were just friends yeah we were
we were friends my main friend in the
band was
tony okay he was like
you know we would keep in touch over the
years and if he was in town
he'd say do you want to come to the show
i'll leave you some tickets you know it
was one of those sort of things
we weren't like buddies speaking every
week
but you know we would stay in touch
loosely and
that was it right and for people who
aren't quite as plugged in tony is tony
iomie
the lead guitarist really the the face
of black sabbath
you know aside from ozzie i wasn't
getting the president that she was tour
manager
no no no i managed the whole program
though they put everything together
yeah for awesome absolutely i was tour
manager while i was on the road with
electric light orchestra and i was
mainly their tour manager
oh cool yeah so there's i've heard these
these
i suppose you would call them myths or
legends
but uh of course you know a lot of
people know that ozzy
before he was in black sabbath he worked
in a slaughterhouse
in uh in england and so he was sort of
you know comfortable with with death and
and this and that and so i heard it i'm
dying to find out if this is true
but that when there were meetings for
ozzie to get a uh a
record deal for his solo career for his
first album which is a bona fide
greatest hits album blizzard of oz
like going into these meetings i heard a
story
that uh that you directed ozzie to walk
in with a live dove in one hand and a
dead dove in the other
and that he would go into the the board
room
and and bite the head off of the dead
dove and spit it on the
board room table and release the live
dubs it would fly around the room
and then just turn around and walk out
is there any truth to that
being able to ask sharon osborne about
that story is so cool
you know what else is cool my cats
and i love them so much of course
i have a litter robot what's that it's a
self-cleaning cat litter machine
and that makes it so that my cats don't
have to stand in their own poop
to poop and i don't ever have to clean
up the poop
see there's a sensor that detects
when they go in there and it gives them
seven minutes to do their thing and then
it cleans itself how does that work
it just rotates
and then it sifts out the poop
drops it down into the drawer below this
is without me doing
anything at all i get a notification on
my phone
that says your litter robot drawer is
full
there it is you just replace the bag
maybe
once a week and your house never stinks
like kitty litter
your cats are happy and healthy you
can't beat it
so how do you get one you go to
catpoop.com
and buy yourself a litter robot buy it
today and the shipping is completely
free
and you get a 90 day money back
guarantee
that's right but there's no way you're
gonna [ __ ] send this thing back
because it's the dopest invention ever
made
so again go to catpoop.com and get
yourself
a litter robot yeah dude
okay it's it's you got bits of it right
the deal
was he was to go in because it was his
first
introduction to the record company
they'd never met him
so they were having you know all the
staff come into the conference room and
he was going to
you know walk in and you've got to
remember this was like
81 probably or something 81
18 no it was 80 i think or 81
anyway nobody gave a [ __ ] about aussie
it was a cheap deal they were doing him
a favor putting the record out they
didn't know about this genre of music
at all why because ozzy created it
they knew nothing about this music and
so he goes in there and all these people
are like you know
listening to crazy train they they've
got no [ __ ] idea what they're
listening to
and we said take the doves
and let them go and it's like a peace
offering everybody will go oh
how gorgeous that's lovely and
you know we'll walk out so was he goes
in he's
already drunk and it's the morning it's
like 10 in the morning
so he's got a dove in each pocket he
sits on this girl's
lap who he has no idea who she is
so he sits on her lap he does the vibe
in the room is very strange
and he looks at everybody
they look at him and he takes the dove
out and he just
rips the head off and spits it on the
girl's lap
that was it over game over he then gets
the other one and lets the other one
free in the room so it's flying and
[ __ ] in the room
and then we got ushered out by security
and that was it and that was with the
the record label
to actually sort of pitch the record
deal
oh no the deal was done it was okay this
is aussie you've just signed him
it was like a meet and greet oh gotcha
i'm great
because i was it under just like hi
you know and that was it i got back to
the office
i got a call from legal they said if you
ever do this again we won't release the
album
and we'll literally destroy you and
we're like oh
okay thanks wow
so that's uh i'm pretty proud to even
know that story because i was looking
for it on wikipedia
and there was nothing about it yeah
and um and and here's the this is what's
just again i'll keep going back to it
because to be kicked out of black
sabbath and then go on to have the solo
career which just utterly eclipses
anything that sabbath ever did
and then after that all these years
later the the black sabbath reunion
i've gotta you know i've gotta guess you
being the shrewd
you know business mind behind the aussie
empire
and the way that the world works when
black sabbath gets reunited with ozzie
now it's going to be on your terms and
essentially all of the other people in
black sabbath are going to be
employees of the band is that about
writers
it's about right but aussie and tony
own the name and
bill don't so it's aussie and tony that
own the name
and they are partners in black sabbath
so you're kind of right aussie and tony
are equal
and at that time the other guys
you know it's kind of like pay for play
yeah
what do you call it a jam session
employee
um now i wonder this is a
somewhat similar situation but with
motley crew
where there's all kinds of uh different
accounts or
there's vince neil's version of he got
kicked out and the others say he left
but of course ultimately vince neil came
back to motley cru
as an employee is that is that right
i don't know i honestly don't know but
um i know that they are kind of each on
different deals i know that but i don't
know what any of the deals are
right i just i'm so fascinated by the
business of it all
and um then okay so
after ozzy left black sabbath then they
get ronnie james dio
yeah and the the world's just not that
happy about sabbath without
ozzy right i mean dio's a lovely guy or
he was a lovely guy
he was a great talent but sabbath never
really
did very well with dio did they they had
two hit albums they did they had two
good hit albums
they had two good tours together and
um then it was
the band were fighting
there was a lot of fighting in the band
with ronnie
so um i you know what ronnie had a great
voice
but to to change a band that had a kind
of bluesy
type vocal real gritty bluesy vocal
to a rock opera vocal it was so
different
because i i always looked at ronnie as a
rock
opera type singer you know
it was one of those and ozzy had such a
bluesy voice
i i never got it right so then dio
left sabbath and tony became the singer
of sabbath and that's when they
really didn't do that great yeah well
they kept getting all these different
guys in i mean
every week it was somebody else and
somebody else you know
and they were doing you know really
badly and
taking silly gigs you know like playing
you know under somebody they weren't the
headliner anymore
and always when you go from that
headliner to okay
now you're underneath and you're on
somebody else's tour
and for so long it's your tour and
you're the headline and then you drop
it's very kind of final tap
very spinal tap um and
so when dio left sabbath he put out
holy diver that was his first album
because god that's a good album
he's good yeah so on his own dio's great
great absolutely and um ozzy of course
ozzy
how much uh with with mtv coming out
right was uh like bark at the moon was
one of the first like
really big videos on mtv
like uh that that helped explode ozzy's
success
it did it did it broadened his you know
his audience a lot
it did and then there was the legend of
biting the head off of the bat
you had to know it was a pretty safe bit
that we were going to talk about
ozzy biting the head off of the bat
because it's a crazy story
but do you know what's a 100 guarantee
that i will always in my pocket
have this the case for my raycon
e25 earbuds that's right i've said it
before
if you ever catch me without it in my
pocket
without my connie 25 earbuds i will
record
your voicemail greeting whatever little
shout out video you want for your
buddies
because i'm never going to get caught
without them i love them
i can't stand working out without
listening to music
and when i'm working out you think i
want big clunky earphones on
now it's hot and uncomfortable these are
not only comfortable
but they're half the price of any other
premium earbuds out there
and unlike all those other premium
earbuds
these ones you can actually control
pause
skip track all the rest of it dude
they're so comfortable in here i can
have my head resting on my pillow and
feel fine they're the best and
if you go to buy raycon.com
stevo you can get yourself some for 15
off that's right 15 off if you go to buy
raycon.com
stevo i mean to work out
listen to tunes and just be the man
now let's talk about that bat which
which everybody knows about and they
sent him to get these crazy rabies shots
which back then went through your
stomach
and and were really that was a
huge deal that was a huge deal i mean he
it might have been like a mistake and
like funny as [ __ ] at the time
but then he had to pay for it by getting
all these shots that you take over a
long period of time
and we were all really frightened for
him
yeah i mean the shots that were like
huge long needles that
go into your stomach and how long did
they have to give them four
oh over six months oh wow
so so when you're traveling with them
and you see ozzy bite the head off of
bat like what's your expression while
you're there like
what the [ __ ] did he just do or is it
funny i was like oh my god
first thing i think of rabies that's it
it's over
you know right and then there's these
these i mean i wouldn't even call them
myths or legends but this like
folklore which which i just
they would say that ozzy would have the
the
uh the crowd pass a bucket around and
everybody spits in the bucket and then
it goes on stage and he drinks the
bucket you've heard those ones before
yeah
yeah and there's no you know me there is
no way i would ever ever know that
that is like you know it's like uh
johnny cut his finger off
and the next he's cut his head off you
know right get exaggerated
and right like richard gere was the
gerbil and
yeah right
so uh all of this just incredible
history and i love it so
and again blizzard devos that that was
aussie's first solo album yeah i mean
if if that's not a greatest hits album i
would i don't know
suicide solution crazy
an all-time classic album it's
it's it's unbelievable and uh and and
with all the my
my first concert was twisted sister but
uh was it my i think my second concert
was uh the ultimate sin tour
oh wow and uh ozzy wasn't in very good
shape in 87
no he wasn't i remember i remember him
like going back
back and forth across the stage and it
really tiring him out
it was probably loaded at the time right
for sure
and then of course the osborne's comes
out on mtv
and this is a this is this a little bit
broke my heart because
jackass came out in the year 2000
and set absolute records for ratings it
was the highest rated show in the
history of mtv
until you guys came along and you can
imagine how i felt because
we were out here breaking our bones and
just
like absolutely murdering ourselves for
these ratings
and then you guys stroll along and
you're sitting in the living room and
you're more popular than us
just hanging out at home
and and god bless you for it what uh
like what what it what a revival
and and the osborne's came before oz
fest
yeah um no i
came before yeah wow so i didn't i i
thought of oz fest as a little bit
newer no us fest came before yeah
but you know what it was it was like we
were the festival
that every kid wanted to go to but
it was like under it was kind of
underground
people didn't want to write about it
they didn't want to speak about it
because we weren't the
it's thing to go to you know
lollapalooza was and we were like this
bunch of
crazy ass that nobody wanted to write
about but
we were going out and doing you know
sell out business everywhere and just
doing our thing
but quietly yeah i mean i think oz fest
was a little bit more edgy with like
slipknot i think
maybe you guys had it and it's like you
know that
genre of music has never been too
popular with the press
never right i've always felt that
they looked at it as if they were the
bastards of the music industry
yeah no it wasn't chic it's not you two
it's not the stones it's not you know
lollapalooza so it's not chic to be seen
at
you know but it was certainly a rebirth
for ozzy
oh it was it was just phenomenal to be
able to
to go out every summer and give these
young bands a stage and you know
see these bands that were you know not
even signed at the time then suddenly
you know the year later they've got a
huge hit album
it was just exciting so exciting i think
lamb of god would be one of those bands
maybe yeah absolutely
yeah sleep not hadn't got their album
released at the time
either it was just unbelievable and you
think you know
incubus and all those great bands that
we had
yeah um i think uh that the success of
ozzy's solo career is
is really about just the the caliber of
musicians that have been behind him i
mean
i like back to randy rhodes and you know
jakey lee all these just incredible
musicians
and what was the process like for
getting the
for finding these musicians to perform
with ozzy to put the band together it
was
really really hard hard hard
it's not something that just happens you
know
it's um it's really hard it's a long
process but
it's aussie has always you know to go
from tony naomi
yeah he could not go less than
so to find somebody that
is so creative but young
was you know it was a gift from god
yeah i i just i just love it so much
and your career on your like
when did you get into all the television
stuff on your own
only from when we did the osborns
and then that was it i never thought i
always loved to do my business side and
creative side and do that
and then it just came organically from
the osborne's
right safe to say that you're kris
jenner
before kris jenner as far as being like
the momager the the the the business
mind
that builds the empire behind the scenes
yeah
yeah i i love it and uh you know i
they started going what do you like
doing more do you like uh you like
touring and doing band stuff or do you
like going to the studios and doing tv
shows and air conditioning and
i do know what they're both so different
but they both
are great but there's nothing like
seeing that live audience those
kids that just gives off so much
energy and love and it's just there's
nothing like seeing a
festival audience you know it just gives
me chills to this day
i love it yeah it's giving me chills too
i mean the amount of people you put on
the map just from doing that is
incredible
it's so funny because scott asks what do
you like better the touring or the tv
studios
and in my mind i'm thinking or do you
like
bending people's will to dominate them
in business
and uh because that's how i think of you
i just love it so much
that the just the way that you're the
the puppet master it feels like and and
and what
what a wonderful family you have just
last week
i was with this this professional
skateboarder
who rides what's called the mega ramp
where he comes down like
and flies like through arenas and with
the x games
and uh i mentioned to him that i was
going to be talking to you
and he said dude i've got i've got this
great story
he said that he was at the beach and and
uh going the wrong way he had to do a
u-turn
but his car got stuck in the sand right
on the boardwalk
and there he is and the wheels are just
spinning he said all these people are
just going by
laughing at me nobody's doing anything
and then all of a sudden after i've been
there for a while with all these people
going by
somebody says hey man let me help you
out
you've gotta uh let the air out of your
tires and and here come on we'll do it
together
and that was jack osborne yeah he's a
good
guy he is he had no idea who elliot
sloane was
this is elliot sloan the professional
mega ramp superstar
and jack osborne didn't know that it's
just testimony that jack would do that
for
anybody in that situation and we we sat
next to jack on the plane and we had a
good conversation with them
i don't remember where we're coming back
from but we were coming back from costa
rica picking up our fifth dog
oh yeah and he was coming back from
doing i think
a tv show with ozzy at the grand canyon
or they're doing something
yeah yeah it's just and i i have quite
the history with jack i remember
he was newly sober and i believe 2005
and somehow he ended up over at my
apartment where there was just a few of
us just getting cross-eyed drunk
but we all and jack stayed stayed
completely sober and we all just had
this
riotous good time and uh he's always
been
been a real bloke i think everybody yeah
he
is he's a good bloke exactly but do you
know what
i always look at you and i look at jack
and i see what jack did and you've
done it and it's just amazing oh it's
it's such a
blessing it's such a blessing you know
what people say that they
there there's no such thing as miracles
but they are
because for me this is a miracle oh you
got to believe in foolish miracles
sharon
yeah i i and um uh yeah that just made
me
it warms it warms my heart and i just
wish you could you could uh
bestow upon people the willingness to do
the work of recovery
but you know but you can't and and i
don't know what gave me that willingness
or jack for that matter but god i'm
grateful for both of us
but was there one point that you said
this is it
i can't anymore i was yeah it was when
knoxville locked me up in the
psychiatric ward
and and they decided to keep me for a
couple weeks
that was enough time for the was it then
or was it the 52-50
well that's what that got taken into the
segway on 51.50 and they
turned it into 52.50 so that means that
they could keep me
scott's an example of uh of the miracle
recovery as well here
it's uh yeah it's great i was at the uh
the premiere there was a premiere the
screening
of uh the the documentary that jack made
about ozzy yeah
and uh god if if tommy lee isn't the
star of that when he tells the story
about ozzy smearing the [ __ ] all over
the hotel room walls
oh my god and tommy throwing up yeah
oh man so it's so so brilliant and
so then the osborne's came out you get
into all kinds of television stuff
like like uh judging on the x factor and
and eight well no no don't say that if
you bite your tongue you take that back
it's the talk
the time i'm sorry i'm sorry yeah you
don't see the viewer
around here i'm sorry when my dad worked
for for
sorry it's like when my dad worked for
pepsi you're gonna walk in with a coke
ah so what and and uh
what was it like working with howard
stern
on agt god well i i was a friend of his
anyway
so to work together was the
best we had a really really great time
together
so much fun so much fun it was just
brilliant i loved that gig yeah and then
and i was sad when you left but uh but
you you
you were across with nbc for their
treatment of jazz i was
very cross with nbc particularly a guy
called porter legley and this woman
meredith
heir they they did
very badly by jack who at the time was
going through so much because he'd just
been diagnosed with ms
and he was completely
without any um self-respect as a man he
just got married he had a child
he had no work and he wanted to be able
to provide for his family
and he um they gave him a gig and then
they took it away from him
and i was so upset with them so upset
that um i just basically i called them
all
arseholes [ __ ] told them all to
[ __ ] themselves and then i was leaving
yeah um i i'd never seen anything like
it because then they said oh
the most insulting thing was um oh well
we'll pay him
we'll just send him money and i'm like
no you don't
get it he's he needs his self-respect he
needs to work
oh well we'll pay him and it's like no
they could have said
well we'll give money to an ms charity
in his name
but none of that it was just oh you know
throw a check at him and they'll shut up
they didn't give a [ __ ] so no i never
wanted to
to um work with those people again
i love how how you stand up for what you
believe in sharon
yeah but do you know what i'm in a very
very blessed position and i realize it
because i'm in a position where
i don't have to do it i do it because i
really love doing it
so i can say to people [ __ ] off
i'm not taking it whereas so many people
can't you know they can't and that's why
so many people
are so badly treated right because they
need the gig
right um and and the talk
what's going on with the talk now um
well we're doing it from home you know
we're doing it through zoom every day
so um i i actually love it because i
don't have to leave the house
oh there is so much about about this
doing things remotely
that that i want to hang on to once the
coronavirus is enrolled
i kind of prefer going to 12-step
meetings on zoom instead of in person
it's just kind of nice to
sit in your underwear well especially in
la when it takes an
hour to drive anywhere and then an hour
to drive
back when you can just get into the
business of what you're doing and
and uh it's it's pretty convenient
um and and uh i i saw on your wikipedia
you have uh
the the record for the the top
selling book in the history of uh
of books in england yeah i do
i know i who would have thought it's
fantastic
that that uh what book is that it's one
of sharon's three autobiographies sorry
let me not answer your question for you
yeah it's called survivor and it was um
that one was about uh my you know
meeting aussie growing up as a child in
the industry
and meeting aussie and you know us
some of our life together so it's um
it's a good book i think yeah i was
actually
sorry i was curious about some of that
like what was ozzy like when you met him
was he always
that like this kind of crazy guy or did
that develop over time
um he was always always
very nice guy funny he was
so funny and that's what attracted me to
him because he was
naughty but he um i think
as the drinking and drug taking
progressed with aussie
he got more dangerous
and his his behavior was much
more dangerous you know it wasn't so
funny towards the end
sure what i'm dying to know is because
i'm a tour manager for steve and when we
go
travel you know like our rider is just
soda water
for the green room all we ask for is
soda water and you were doing these
bands
you know what are some of the
interesting writers that like elo did or
ozzy wanted or
black sabbath do you know what we
i have always told everybody that i work
with whatever you have on your rider
you pay for nice you know you're
allotted
a certain amount maybe you're allotted
from the promoter but everything over
that you pay for
so if you want a sushi chef and you want
a huge
party after the show it's on your dime
so you know just have the bare
bare bones because you don't need it you
don't want it you're only going to throw
it up the wall anyway
aussies has always been you know minimum
same as sabbath and yellow it was very
very
you know loki
how did the uh collaboration with post
malone come about
oh it came about through kelly
um kelly knew one of the producers
for post malone who had just done i'll
come up with an idea for a new song
and said that um ozzy would be perfect
to do a duet with um post and so
kelly then came to us and so that's how
it started through kelly
okay it's amazing how big this post
malone character is
isn't it it's incredible and what what
i find fascinating is is that his
image is so much harder than his music
yeah right yeah look at the image and
you go
what the hell is this and his audience
is very young
right i know it's it's i mean i think
his audience is just
everybody he's so big yeah so
he's a good guy he's a very good guy
everybody says that about post malone
like he couldn't be nicer yeah yeah
yeah that's all you ever hear very nice
humble you know sweet guy he really is
for sure um and now with the random
questions over here but what was it like
to
to work with donald trump on the
celebrity apprentice
oh my lord
very interesting put it that way very
interesting it was at the time you know
that he did it in the trump tower
and all of that and he he's just
um
he's i can remember we went into his
apartment and we had to wear surgical
things over our shoes so we didn't get
the place
dirty and we went in there and it was
like my
grandmother's um
my grandmother would have loved it in
there you know a lot of gold and a lot
of
velvet and it was you know it was just
like
an old lady's apartment they've like
couch protectors over his couches and
they might as well you know but they did
have one of those
portraits of him and his wife done on
black you know they do it with the
charcoal
they used to do like asian ladies that
were done with the black background you
know and they would sit like this
i mean just the worst art you've ever
seen in your life
but oh and i think he had um a water
feature with plants in
in the apartment i mean just terrible
and he was i he was um
just weird you know did you see my
receptionist did you see her
did you see how beautiful nobody has a
receptionist like i do
she's gorgeous she's like she looks just
like my daughter yeah
oh man and and and so
with i'm just bouncing all over but this
has just been so
so thrilling for me um how's ozzie doing
now
he's doing good he's doing really really
good you know he's
he's some had terrible
terrible injury that you know at one
point they thought he would never walk
again but he is he's walking
he's doing great and you know he's been
hit by
so much medically um but
he's he's doing good he is he's getting
stronger every day
yeah was that the spine injury you're
talking about
yeah that you think brought on the the
gene oh god i mean the
to be hit with the you know the spinal
injury
and then what it had done was it kind of
um started off the parkinson's that he
had the gene for
but was never activated he just had the
gene
it's like having you know the breast
cancer gene but it never comes into
fruition it never
gets alive and he had the parkinson gene
and this
accident just sparked it off so he had
he kind of had a double dose of
everything
but he's doing good yeah i mean
it's uh it's it's
heartbreaking it's heartbreaking to see
this at you know he's had this ride in
his life and then suddenly
boom and like you are flawed and to have
your
health taken away no matter what what
you've got
money wise or anything in the world
can't fix
right but uh but he's still
thriving in his career yeah oh my god
what about his album i
mean just incredible the album was
sensational
it um it you know
he's starting his second album with
andrew watt right now
and you know he's he's you can't stop
him
you know he's he's doing it yeah oh it's
fantastic
well i i think yeah ozzy says that he
as far as performing goes he
has to end it his way because it was his
farewell tour that he was on
but he still had a year to do of that
tour
and there were seats sold for the next
year but you know
the accident stopped it all but he said
it's not gonna win just like that it's
gonna end
his way and he's gonna go back out and
even if it's just
one huge show to say goodbye he's going
to do it
so i love it i love it
well i'll tell you what sharon this has
been everything
that i i imagined everything i i
hoped for and uh you're just so
fantastic so wonderful and
and uh just loads and loads of love to
you and your whole family
bless you thank you i have to ask you
once
of course ask me anything you'd like
yeah tell me about your dog
this is wendy i found her in the streets
of peru
and uh it's i was in peru for three
weeks and she followed me everywhere i
went
she has her own t-shirt too the fresh
princess of hollywood
yeah and i made a video
of uh of finding her i was actually
filming when i found her
and uh you know i slept with a tent
outside the hotel because they wouldn't
let her in the hotel
and um and this video i made
of finding wendy and bringing her home
it it uh
it garnered more views than anything
i've ever put on the internet
which uh god she is beautiful
right is that she she goes at my speed
if i go fast she goes fast if i'm
sitting there
she's sitting there what so how many
dogs have you rescued
uh well we had five but we
one didn't really work out so we
re-homed that one uh we've got four dogs
at the house
two cats and three goats in the backyard
i love it yeah whoa
yeah i love it it's so good to see you
doing so well
well thank you i appreciate that so so
much and uh
kelly she's uh rocking it in sobriety
yeah
she is she is she's doing just great she
is
thank god all my love to to all of your
family
everybody it's uh it's it's such an
honor such a treat
and uh and and thank you i don't know
about you but i think that was
the greatest and as i always say thank
you so much to you guys who stuck in
there to the very end
i'm guessing that this going out in
two days have i already sent the street
team a text
i'm not sure if it's not already
where you've got the [ __ ] first
access to the gnarly comedy special
it's imminent so yeah do that whole
[ __ ]
text me thing and uh the street team
gets it first
[ __ ] yeah love you guys